in 2020 650 000 people moved out of
california
including myself last year another
nearly 700 000 people moved out of
california since 2010 about 8 million
people have moved out of california to
freer pastures
many many more people than have moved
into california from other places the
state is hemorrhaging people because of
onerous taxes crippling regulations
rampant crime and streets lined with
needles and human excrement but
governor patrick bateman american psycho
himself has figured out a way to lure
people back to the golden state and that
is
to let them kill their babies
that'll do it right
this week california state legislators
advanced an amendment to enshrine a
license to contraception and abortion
in the state constitution
governor bateman believes this will do
it he says we want you back come back
come back come on please here we go
we're going to be the land of
the free free quote unquote the freedom
to kill your babies in the long run
this is very bad
we don't want babies in california to be
killed any more than we want babies in
any other state to be killed
no state no community has the right to
kill little babies even if every single
person in the state votes to legalize it
and that is because abortion is contrary
to natural law
i don't think this is even going to
achieve what newsom wants which is to
convince the people to move back to
california
but
but
it might convince
more liberal californians to stay
in california in the short term this
might be a political benefit to avoid
packing up their lives and shoving off
to the red states in the first place it
may make inertia even more appealing and
keep the libs in california which in the
short run would do the great service of
confining the poison of leftist policies
it may
slow the spread of epidemic leftism to
the rest of the country but
conservatives cannot kick back and rest
easy conservatives need to take this
opportunity that the left is giving us
we are winning
we are winning
specifically on the so-called social
issues
now is the time to strengthen our
communities our red states prove the
superiority of our way of life
rally the political troops and then
retake the blue states too i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from jordan
elizabeth who says the lady who founded
march for life nellie gray was born on
june 24th too the so-called coincidences
keep on coming that's amazing june 24th
the day that dobbs comes down the day
that roe is overruled the day that is
the feast of the sacred heart of jesus
the day on which traditionally would be
the nativity of saint john the baptist
who leaps in his mother's womb when
jesus in his mother's womb approaches a
day when there is a five planet
alignment the photo of the five planet
alignment taken by a man named wright
dobbs in all of the newspapers and now
it's also the birthday of the lady who
founded march for life
all nature is but art unknown to thee
all chance direction which thou cast not
see
when you want to relate that and other
very interesting lines of poetry to your
friends you're probably going to need a
phone and you got to get pure talk right
now go to puretalk.com enter promo code
knowles podcast
the american people are getting pinched
right now you are getting pinched right
now gas is going way way up everything
that you're buying at the store is going
way way up if you're like me you're
probably looking at your budget right
now
one way that you can really save a lot
of money is on your cell phone plan
because your cell phone companies those
big cell phone companies are charging
you a bazillion dollars what are you
paying you're probably paying 70 80 90 a
month per line
for what for the exact same service that
you could get from puretalk for 30 a
month
all the talk you want all the text you
want all the data that you want for 30 a
month on america's best 5g network why
on earth would you pay those gigantic
awful cell phone companies when you
could go to pure talk great supporter of
this show give us the voicemail bag and
save a lot of money go to puretalk.com
select a plan enter promo code knowles
podcast save 50
off your first month i love puretalk i
use puretalk you should too switch over
in less than 10 minutes promo code
knowles podcast k w l e s podcast all
one word at puretalk.com
i
i don't think
that the license to kill little babies
is going to be enough to bring all the
people who have fled california back i
don't think it's going to convince
someone how sad is that how desperate
that that's all they've got yeah i know
it's terrible to live here and i know
that we're destroying all of our
communities and i know that we're
killing your businesses and taking your
rides and stealing all your money but
hey we'll let you do the most evil thing
i can imagine
you can do that if you want to do that
really evil thing
you can do it here
is that going to do it i don't think so
and they're making life even worse in
california now
san francisco has just decided to
destroy the suburbs this is such an
important story and the libs are pushing
it especially in san francisco but
around the country and there have been
fights over this going back to the obama
administration
over whether or not to allow people to
keep the suburbs
whether or not to allow nice communities
with single
family homes and lots
or to get rid of single-family zoning
and make everything into some big ugly
apartment building so that you can pack
more people in and destroy the to quote
donald trump the suburban lifestyle
dream well the san francisco board of
supervisors
just passed this legislation
two days ago to eliminate single-family
zoning
it will now allow four plexes on every
neighborhood lot and six units on corner
properties this builds on something i
mentioned at the end of the show
yesterday which is
if if we want people to be conservative
we need to
have people like
their homes
like their country we need to give them
a country that is beautiful and lovable
and pleasant to be in this was a point
that the late conservative philosopher
roger scrutin made when he actually had
a government post in charge of housing
in the in the country in in the uk
he said if you if you want to
make people want to conserve something
you need to give them something worth
conserving the libs do not want us to
live in a beautiful place the libs do
not want us to live in a lovable place
they want us to live in some dingy tiny
little apartment where we own nothing
and we'll be happy that's what they want
they want us to be packed in like rats
and and the reason for this i think gets
to their view of humanity
i think that the libs
you'll frequently hear the libs talk
about the masses you know the unwashed
masses that religion is the opiate of
the masses just masses
masses of what conservatives generally
don't talk about the masses we talk
about people because we like people and
we view them as individually very
important and as working together in a
community and having dignity and having
worth and the libs say no it's just
masses
these masses are creating a problem of
overpopulation we've got we're just
going to kill them through abortion or
through euthanasia we're just going to
treat them like refuse like nothing and
then we're going to cram them into these
ugly giant buildings and not give them a
beautiful home where they can thrive in
the in in the suburbs or wherever they
can find themselves now of course the
libs who are running things they have
their nice single family homes they just
don't want you to have it they don't
want you to have nice places we're gonna
pack in
all of the underclass in some filthy
tenement and then we i nancy pelosi i'm
gonna go live in my mansion outside of
san francisco
i don't think nancy pelosi is going to
go live in a quadruplex i don't think
nancy pelosi is going to go move into
some
ugly apartment building
that's just for you that's just for
everybody else
not that's not a that's not a good way
to live
but it ties in with all of the other
ties in with the social issues it ties
in with the economic issues they don't
they don't want to give people lovable
places where they can thrive speaking of
nancy pelosi and reasons not to move to
california there's a scandal that's just
come out with pelosi
which is that pelosi just visited the
vatican and apparently got to meet the
pope and then later at a papal mass
received communion received the
eucharist
this has been a big political battle
because
in the catholic church to which nancy
pelosi at least pretends to
adhere
you you do not receive the eucharist if
you are in a state of grave mortal sin
and the reason you're not supposed to do
that is not just because it causes
scandal to everyone else but because
saint paul says that if you eat the
eucharist unworthily
you are eating your own damnation
so it's not good for you to do it's
actually a sin to do that
nancy pelosi does it anyway her
archbishop has a great backbone his name
is cor di leone means heart of a lion
archbishop cor de leone says listen uh
i'm instructing all the priests in this
diocese do not
do not
give the eucharist to nancy pelosi
that's bad for her and it's bad for the
flock which will be led astray so then
she goes to the vatican
and it's it's unclear i don't i don't
think the pope himself gave nancy pelosi
to the eucharist at a papal mass there
are lots and lots of people distributing
the host but she she did present herself
to receive it and this is this is a
great scandal
ties in with another sort of scandal
that's come out of the vatican which is
that the the pope has tried to get rid
of the latin mass he's really trying to
suppress the latin mass and i know for
the people listening who are not
catholic who are not particularly
traditional who maybe aren't christian
at all maybe they aren't even religious
this story really matters too i know it
doesn't seem like it would if you're not
attending the latin mass or you're not
catholic but it really does and it it
does because of a principle in
christianity that applies to our entire
american life and the principle in latin
is
lex arandi lex credenti lex vivendi it
means the way that we pray
is the way that we believe
is the way that we live this idea that
the way in which we worship god the way
in which we worship anything really is
going to really probably determine
the way that we believe the way that we
think about god or whatever we worship
and it's going to affect the way that we
live our lives because we're incarnate
beings we have bodies and ritual matters
and we and where we spend our time is
where we place value it's what we it's
what we think is really meaningful it's
why the liturgy is so important but it's
why the the liturgy of the way that we
live our lives is so important okay if
we
if we pray
and worship
money
then we are going to believe that money
is the most important thing and we're
going to live our lives in a very
materialist way if we pray
it is if we worship sex or pornography
or some kind the hook-up culture or
something like that we're going to
believe that that is the most important
thing that just getting at our sort of
animal aggression and instincts and
and things like that is the most
important thing and we're going to live
like animals
or if we worship god and specifically if
we worship god in a reverent way in the
way that he asks us to in the bible then
we're going to believe
in that way we're and we're going to
live our lives in that way that's very
elevated you can't ignore it even even
if you think you're an atheist even if
you think you're agnostic you can't
escape that because
you got a body you got a body and the
way that you use your body in the way
that you spend your time and the way
that you worship because man is a
religious being and everybody's got to
serve somebody that's going to affect
the way that you believe about
everything and it's going to affect
every other aspect of your life when
you've got people leading others into
scandal
that creates a big public problem
whether you're catholic whether you
consider yourself broadly christian or
whether you don't consider yourself any
of those things at all
now when we want to do things with our
bodies do things ourselves one of those
things we might do is fix our cars which
is why you got to check out rock auto
right now go to rockauto.com enter
knowles in there how did you hear about
xbox the value of your minivan your
pickup your sedan whatever you drive
probably appreciated pretty
significantly last year so take care of
your automotive investment and keep more
of your money by buying the auto parts
that you need to maintain and repair
your vehicle at rockauto.com
they have got the auto parts you need
they will give you a selection of
trusted name brands to choose from an
incredibly easy to navigate website
buddy of mine i mentioned this a week or
so ago buddy of mine goes to the brick
and mortar auto port store
he made a mistake he apologized he knew
it was dumb to do that he goes to the
store he tries to get a part for his car
that he wanted right away
they wanted to charge him 400 he says
wait a second i know rockauto.com has
been sponsoring the michael knowles show
for years let me go check out their very
easy catalog oh here's the same part the
exact same part for 150
so what are you doing you guys this is
highway rivalry here at this brick and
mortar shop don't make his mistake go
straight to rockauto.com for your auto
parts write knolls in their how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you
speaking of religion really unfortunate
story coming out of hollywood and
religion
it's about chris pratt
chris pratt is a movie star
probably the most popular movie star in
the world right now
he has become
a voice for
christians
he has become a voice for maybe kind of
conservatives i don't know or at least
non-leftists
he did this because he was at an awards
show and he spoke about god and he said
god loves you there is a god god loves
you and you should have a relationship
with god something to that effect i'm
paraphrasing but that's what he said and
it was so refreshing to see because the
rest of hollywood usually in their
speeches insinuates there is a moloch
you should you should sacrifice to
moloch you should give your you should
sell your soul to the devil and they
always say the opposite of what chris
pratt said so it's very refreshing to
see that now chris brett is coming out
he's saying i'm not a religious person
and it's this it's being reported in a
lot of places but it's a very long
interview in men's health and
uh chris says look i'm i'm not really a
religious person
i i think religion has been oppressive
af
for a long time i don't know how i be
came to be viewed as this voice of
religion people said that i went to
hillsong church which i guess is not
down with the rainbow they're not the
most lgbt church in the world and i've
never been to hillsong church
and it was it was just
really sort of sad to see again it's
such a long interview i can't even find
the exact quote it's fine though it
doesn't really matter what the exact
quote is it was just really really sad
to see it was
like in the old days of the
house
committee on un-american activities
and hollywood black listing holly the
hollywood people would be asked are you
now or have you ever been a member of
the communist party
which i firmly uh defend by the way i'm
perfectly fine blacklisting communists
because communists are very bad and
we're subverting our country
now we've got the opposite now we're
having are you now or have you ever been
a christian and chris pratt doesn't
disavow god entirely here he but he
basically says i'm spiritual but not
religious it's really really weak sauce
and i think it's it's dumb for him to do
it
because he's trying to thread this
needle and remain a big hollywood star
in the mainstream but not not get
cancelled but not totally throw away his
beliefs and it's just not
not gonna work man i mean i think this
is
this is kind of what
in the gospels you see spoken of and
what the early christians saw at a
certain point
you're gonna have to pick a side okay if
you if you believe in god if you
believe in the truth and you say true
things and you stand up for the truth
people are going to hate you for it and
then you're going to have to make a
decision do you go with the mob or do
you stick with the truth and do you
stick with god and right now
chris is trying to stand in the middle
and he's trying to he's trying to
thread that needle and have have
everything you you can't you can't do
that
you can't have everything and if the
choices are between
picking the hot the absolute degenerates
in hollywood and fame which even for a
giant star like chris pratt will be
fleeting or the truth and god and what
is right it shouldn't be a hard decision
i know that it is in the moment but it
should not be
a hard decision and there there's a kind
of humility with pratt saying wait why
am i i'm just some big dumb movie star
why am i why are you having me be the
voice of religion and theology and faith
in america but that role has been thrust
on him to some degree and he should he
should step up to it that's it it's it
was a disappointing interview and i hope
he doesn't do it again and i i don't
want to be too hard on him but come on
man toughen up toughen up man what are
you doing
the institutional power is with the libs
okay the the people are with chris pratt
here the people are with god the people
are with
beautiful places the people are with
normal ways of life the people are with
don't trans the kids the people are with
don't kill babies the people are with
all the normal stuff and yet the
institutional power
is all on the opposite side of that the
the institutional power
is pushing extremely fringe views such
as transiting the kids
it's because the uh principalities and
powers and dominations of this world are
on the side of the ruler of this world
who is the devil okay the prince of this
world but but
i don't think that speaks for the
majority of people or our best
inclinations and so
this is where you get populism from
especially the populism of the last few
years
how is it that the people seem normal
but the elites are so crooked and and
wicked and stupid and evil well that's
sort of the way it's always been
and so you've got to kind of pick aside
now the institutional power
is behind bite the institutional power
is behind the democrats no question
about that yet when you look at where
the money is
you look at where the smart money is
where the bets are where the people are
joe biden is not only not the favorite
to win in 2024
he's not even number two there's an
amazing story right now out of
gambling.com which is sometimes more
reliable than public opinion polls
because it shows you where people are
really willing to put their money what
they really think is going to happen
it's not just
a consequence free pie in the sky
they're actually putting a little skin
in the game here and according to
gambling.com
the number one favorite to win in 2024
is donald trump
the number two favorite to win in 2024
the whole presidency
ron desantis
the number three choice
joe biden third favorite
you think this is good news for desantis
i'm actually not sure that it is it
means that he's popular it means that
people like him it means that people
think he's a strong candidate and could
be president all of that's true all of
that's true
but i think it might be bad news for
desantis because i think this is only
going to make donald trump double down
on running
if trump is looking at this right now
and he's saying hold on
the incumbent president is so weak that
not only is he going to lose to me
according to at least this sort of odds
making not only is he going to lose to
him he's going to lose to the other guy
too
okay now i'm definitely going to get in
in
uh 2024. it's even more of an incentive
for trump to run
because the incumbent is even weaker
than he had previously thought and
there's there's no bench kamala harris
is less likable than biden pete buddha
judge is someone that the libs all think
is really likable but he's extremely
unlikable and he's a glib and he's
shallow and he's almost certainly a cia
operative and he takes four months
maternity leave so that he can chest
feed his adopted child or what i don't
whatever the situation is
he's not
he's in the mainstream of the fringe
of the of the people who
are familiar with
management consultant ivy league
educated
socially radical
glib people uh he's not in the
mainstream of the mainstream so he's not
going anywhere elizabeth warren is
totally done who else who do they have
hillary i actually don't think hillary's
to run again she's going to be busy look
she gelaine maxwell is about to go to
prison hillary's got a few things to
take care of before she can think about
2024.
so this is more incentive for a trump to
run tough tough on desantis but we'll
see there and there might just be a
primary and
the guys might get bruised up and that's
that's the way it goes republicans have
clutched
defeat from the jaws of victory before
right now though we are winning right
now no matter what happens in 2024 we
are winning you saw it on all those
supreme court decisions on the second
amendment you saw it on religious
liberty and schools you saw it on
obviously the dobbs decision you're
you're seeing it right now outside of
the court
in education there's a huge win for
conservatives in education took place in
arizona almost nobody is covering it
in arizona right now they have the
empowerment scholarship account program
and previously this was a way for a very
small number of students to take the fed
the taxpayer money from the state that
would go toward their education and
spend it in a small number of
specialized programs
the uh
california legislature has
greatly expanded this
families now can receive over 6 500 per
year per child
without those same restrictions that you
had before so a
whole lot of arizona students will
qualify for this and they can use that
money for private schools yes
or for homeschooling
or for learning pods so it's
homeschooling with a few other families
or for
tutoring or for pretty much any other
kind of educational
service that will fit their family's
needs this is incredibly good news this
is the silver lining one of the silver
linings that comes out of the storm
cloud of covid during kovid parents saw
all the lunacy that their kids were
being taught in schools because of
distance learning and they also
so that obviously pulls them
impels the parents to pull the kids out
of school but then they also realize
wait we don't need this public school
these public schools have failed our
students the teacher unions are shutting
our kids out of schools they're
completely screwing them over just for
their own selfish purposes and so what
do we need them for and it led to a huge
rise in homeschooling now conservatives
can capitalize on this
this is a huge win if we can break the
back of the public schooling system
which from the very beginning has been
for the benefit of libs going back not
just 10 or 20 years going back to horace
mann it has been to create a leftist
consensus in america if you can break
that
and have some christian learning pods
and some tradit just traditional
classical learning pods and some
tutoring and
you would do so so much to transform the
future of the country because classrooms
or crystal balls what happens in the
classroom is just telling you what your
country is going to look like in 20
years play the long game now is the time
the libs are so good at playing the long
game we have an opportunity to do it
here the opportunity is on education
speaking of your kids speaking what will
happen in the future
do you have a will yet go check out epic
will right now go to epicwill.com use
promo code knowles life happens really
fast it can end even faster you picture
yourself i know you say you're going to
live to a ripe old age you're going to
be sitting on the porch with the rocking
chair and it'll all go exactly as you
want that's not usually how life works
out okay if things don't work out
exactly as you think they will you're
going to want to have a plan in place
otherwise the state
and the the woke people who hate your
guts who want to
want to trans your kids and indoctrinate
your whole family and take away all your
property they're going to decide what
happens with your stuff and your kids
your most precious accent don't let them
do that do not do not let that happen
take five minutes to set up a will
through epic will starting at just 119
bucks this will will allow you to choose
who raises your kids
allow you to choose who gets your
belongings the things that you hold dear
go to epicwheel.com right now use promo
code knowles you'll get 10 off epic
will's complete will package takes only
five minutes to set up many many of our
families here at the daily wire are now
protected thanks to epic will how about
you do the same epic will.com enter
promo code knowles and do something for
you and your family today
the social issues
are something that we've been told that
conservatives should not focus on do not
go anywhere near the social issues for
the last 30 40 maybe even 50 years
conservatives have said no just focus on
cutting taxes and regulation
and let the social issues go it's too
divisive we're going to lose on that
this this has been
some of the worst advice that
republicans have ever taken
and there are two issues that prove it
the dobbs decision
the one real hardcore social issue that
the conservatives
did not give up on
was abortion
even though we were told in 1973 it's
over then we were told in 1992 with
casey it's over give it up people hate
it ah republicans just ditch this
abortion stuff and you'll start winning
elections
conservatives didn't give it up they
said it's a pipe dream it's never going
to happen you're never going to overrule
they kept it up kept it up
30 years 40 years
49 years just kept plugging away
pro-life laws
all in the states and the local
communities court cases bringing up to
the supreme court and you know what
happened
we won
and you know what happened our views are
popular and you know what happened we
did exactly what the left has done
in the for the opposite ends what we did
what the left does is they just keep
going they lose okay they lose in court
they're going to keep going they lose in
the legislature okay they're going to
keep going you saw them do this with
the redefinition of marriage
they just pushed and pushed and pushed
and they put it up to a vote they put it
up to a vote in california they lost
they keep pushing pushing pushing
pushing pushing eventually they get
their way in the courts they don't stop
well conservatives have refused to give
up on on that one issue on abortion
huge win
and as far as we can tell right now
basically no political fallout if
anything it's helping conservatives yes
it motivated democrats more according to
polls for the midterm elections
according to those same polls it's going
to motivate republicans even more than
that one of the other kind of social
issues that we haven't given up on is
guns one of our most popular issues
defending the second amendment
absolutely one of our most popular
issues conservatives have rolled over on
pretty much every other social issue
and we've lost them
instantly
but those issues
guns
and abortion kind of funny
there's a i don't think that they're in
conflict with one another but
they are issues of life and death that's
for sure
on those two issues we have maintained a
principled stance not this conciliatory
weak squishy nonsense not this
technocratic well actually you know just
from the perspective of utilitarianism
and deficiency and blah blah blah blah
blah and spreadsheets and eggheads no we
held a principled stance we said no
we're not going to give you a freaking
inch we're actually going to take back
an inch we're going to go inch by inch
like i'm al pacino here okay we're going
to keep just winning and winning and
winning hard hard hard guess what those
are those are the big issues for us that
have won that are propelling us in this
election and in future elections
don't trans the kids in schools we're
not just gonna be conciliatory and say
well you can okay certain bathrooms well
certain sports teams well maybe i don't
know my kid can't wear a dress and high
heels you've got to pick one no we said
no we don't want any of this crap in
schools if you if you do it we're going
to sue you we're going to go in we're
going to kick out your governor in a
blue state
the blue commonwealth of
of virginia we're going to win on that
the social issues are winning issues
principles are winning issues okay don't
don't listen to the squishes the
squishes lost us the country now is the
time to listen to the rock ribbed
conservatives the libs are so upset
about this they're so upset because
conservatives finally
are really
getting aggressive on these social
issues and they're giving the people
what they want and according to the libs
this is a great threat to democracy
i'm a black gay woman and i have a
daughter so i'm not doing so well right
now
i'm a little salty
you're a little salty i'm a little salty
right now okay yeah yeah we'll sprinkle
a little salt yeah
let's put some flavor on this sucks man
it it it really does i mean you know
it's like the
the country it's no longer a democracy
right i mean we're it's no longer
majority rule
no certainly not the senate certainly
of the supreme court it's not it's not
it's no longer majority rule i love hear
stephen colbert who is somewhat
intelligent he realizes that what wanda
sykes is saying doesn't make any sense
and so he's trying to
make it seem like it makes sense because
it's no longer a democracy which why
because of the dobbs decision because of
a decision where the judiciary is giving
away power and to say no we're not going
to make a decision about this issue
we're going to give it back to the
people and their representatives we are
going to expand democracy and she says
it's no longer a democracy colbert is
just thinking how do i
how do i make this extremely dumb
statement sound like it might sort of he
goes yes well certainly not yeah not
when it comes to
the judiciary and the supreme court or
the senate and the supreme court
the the
judiciary
the supreme court
were never
democratic exactly they're democratic in
the sense that people vote for electors
and the electors elect the president the
president appoints
the judges and the judges are confirmed
by the senate and the senate previously
was sent by the states and the people
like the state representatives now that
people directly elect the senators so
there's some democratic tie-in but the
supreme court is not supposed to be the
most democratic institution they have a
life tenure for a reason it's to balance
out the tyranny of the majority
and then the senate is
fairly democratic it's not a one-to-one
uh representation of the people in the
country but it it does give
representation to the the various states
and the and they're elected by the
people of this state so
he's trying to thread this needle she's
seeing this really dumb
dumb point but then she gets to
a really key political lesson
the problem is that middle stuff
it's those states in the middle that
that red stuff
why they get to tell us what to do when
the majority of us live
out you know new york california and
we're paying for all this crap really i
mean right
we're footing the bill
so that's that's the union it's supposed
to be a representative democracy but it
turns out to be minority rule right now
right right but if we fit in the bill
you know and and and like california if
it will a country be what like the fifth
largest
fourth fifth largest economy so if you
know if i'm fitting the bill know your
position you know what i'm saying
you know for real like look if i say hey
let's go out to dinner you don't get to
pick the restaurant just shut up and eat
there it is shut up and eat so she's
saying the majority of americans live in
new york and california that's not true
that's not even close to true it might
be true in her mind but then she points
out she's saying okay i'm not really
talking about the majority of americans
i'm just talking about the majority of
where the money comes from
i'm not you're right i'm not talking
about democracy because we're talking
about democracy then the people get what
they want and and the people don't
support my radical views
but i'm talking about well i guess i'm
talking about oligarchy i guess i'm
talking about money because yeah you in
this country
while maybe the liberal states are
are not the majority uh we we make all
the money baby all the rich people are
democrats and so if you're not making
all the money and you're not paying for
everything then shut your mouth and do
what we say and let us trans your kids
and let us kill your babies and let us
do whatever the hell we want you know
like democracy right when they say
democracy i've said this for a long time
not the first one to say it but i have
been saying it for a long time
when they say democracy
they mean
liberalism they mean leftism they mean
progressivism when they when they weep
philosophic about our democracy our
sacred democracy what they're referring
to is their oligarchy and you heard it
from wanda sykes and you see stephen
colbert nodding along
they are going to tell us what to do we
have one political advantage here the
political advantage we have is that the
people broadly don't like that stuff and
the people broadly are on our side and
it's time to exercise that political
power they've got a lot of institutional
power we do still have that basic
fact of political power you know
speaking of harnessing the power of the
people
last night was our biggest live event of
the year backstage live at the world
famous ryman auditorium we celebrated
our biggest wins
what is a woman the documentary and the
book which took the world by storm our
summer blockbuster terror on the prairie
which brought gina carano back in a big
big way
then we made some earth shattering
announcements such as the launch of
daily wire plus
this is the new streaming service
for our fast growing library of shows
movies and coming soon animated and live
action kids content
we also dropped the news that i've been
sitting on for a while i knew people
were gonna lose it on this
but the news that jordan peterson has
signed a multi-year deal with daily wire
plus where members will get access to
exclusive content new podcast shows and
more and lobsters lots and lots of
lobsters for everybody we expanded our
existing relationship with prageru where
i host a show i host the book club at
prageru which you can get over there you
get the whole prageru content library at
daily wire and a brand new masters
program with dennis prager coming this
fall the time to join is now
right now head on over to
dailywireplus.com to become a daily wire
plus member that's
dailywireplus.com
we will be right back with the voicemail
bag sponsored by puretalk
welcome back to my favorite time of the
week when i get to hear from you in
the voicemail bag sponsored by puretalk
go to puretalk.com select a plan enter
promo code knowles podcast to save 50
off your first month all right let's get
to the first
question hey michael my name's steven i
have a little bit of a more serious
question for you so
my girlfriend and i have been together
for about two years uh we have a mutual
agreement that we're gonna wait to have
sex until marriage but there's a little
bit of a difference here
she
that she had like a religious awakening
right after college and vowed abstinence
after she graduated and i am actually a
virgin now while we've had this mutual
agreement of abstinence i had never
asked her how many guys she had slept
with but we got into a drunk
conversation last week
and she had told me that by the time she
had sworn abstinence before she had this
religious awakening she had slept with
hold on i wrote it down
she slept with 22 men six women and she
even told me she had two abortions one
which was very early and one which is
which was in a later stage
uh
this kind of has me torn up because now
we both fear god and everything i i
guess my question to you is
if we get married uh do you think god
would still respect our marriage knowing
i mean her body count i guess you could
say
yeah this kind of has been torn up so i
appreciate your advice thank you so much
uh yes of course god would still respect
your marriage marriage is a sacrament
and uh it's
it's a real thing it's it's not
contingent on all sorts of other
questions or on your emotions or on on
even the things that you've done in the
past i mean your your sins can be
forgiven
right you you have the opportunity to
repent
to uh go sin no more to have your sins
be forgiven by god because uh you know
christ dies on the cross for all of our
sins and redeems mankind i'm not sure if
you believe that but
uh i certainly believe that so
so yes uh if your question is will god
respect your marriage yes
if it's a illicit and legitimate
marriage and done in the right way then
yes the the the act of marriage when two
people leave their families and come
together and become one flesh what god
has joined let no man separate that that
is a real action
no matter what your feelings happen to
be now
you might have some trouble with this
and you i would i would work through
that trouble and get past it before you
decide to get married
if this if your girlfriend's passed
everybody's got to pass but if your
girlfriend's past is just too much and
you just can't you're not going to be
able to deal with that well know that
now don't take it out on her later or
leave her or hold it over her head or
anything like that
if if she is truly repented and she
thinks that's all awful and especially
the abortions that you know she's now
firmly opposed to abortion and she's
working through the trauma of that and
you know she sought forgiveness
if you if you can get past that then
certainly you know you can you can get
married and uh
if you can get past it god can get past
it okay i i uh so so long as the
repentance is sincere
uh but but it's a real thing i mean it's
also it's also not something to just
brush aside
that is a
that's a that's a traumatic way of
living
you know all those people to have been
intimate with and then and especially
the abortions it's a very traumatic
experience to go through so you gotta
you gotta also make sure your girlfriend
has worked through that uh as well uh
not not an easy
it it'll be a lot harder for you than it
will be for god but i don't overlook the
part of of you both working through that
yourselves but if you if you can work
through that repent and atone and move
on then
have a good marriage next question
hey michael heather here
i was hoping you could take a few
minutes to debunk some of the
roe v wade
just blatant misinformation that is
spreading around social media right now
i know that this topic hits
home for a lot of people but it's pretty
uh
personal for me given that fact that i
had a miscarriage at 20 weeks and of
course that is
that is determined to be a quote-unquote
spontaneous abortion and i really
don't love the fact that the left is
using that to say oh see
that would not be allowed under
some of these trigger laws which is 100
false so i would love if you could just
shed some clarity on that for those who
might fall prey to the misinformation
being spread right now thanks michael
really good question i'm so sorry to
hear about that miscarriage yeah this is
another example of the libs manipulating
language to blur lines and try to get
through their own radical agenda until
very recently and i guess still in some
clinical ways a miscarriage was known as
a spontaneous abortion
an abortion might be known as
infanticide okay
during the quote-unquote abortion rights
movement you see a kind of blurring of
the lines there and that now abortion
comes it comes to be comes to refer to
this procedure where a woman goes in and
sees a butcher and then the butcher
kills her baby in her womb and then
takes the baby out
but those are obviously categorically
different things i've seen this
this canard as well that if you have a
miscarriage
you can no longer
treat that because that would be
considered an abortion
to be clear even using that phrase
spontaneous abortion that occurs
at the moment of the miscarriage
you you can't
you can't abort a baby that has already
died
an abortion is when you kill a baby who
was alive who then will be killed
through that action
so no no there is no law in the country
there's no pro-life law in the country
that does not permit a woman to treat a
miscarriage that is just completely made
up and it's it's
it shows the desperation of the
pro-abortion movement here and you saw
that desperation in the descent on dobbs
the descent in dobbs from the liberals
who didn't want to overrule roe v wade
barely talked about roe v wade barely
talked about planned parenthood v casey
didn't really make a legal or
constitutional argument for either of
those decisions other than its precedent
it was precedent it was decided the
doctrine of story decisis means we have
to we can never overrule any decision
which is completely absurd they didn't
really make a legal argument then they
just said and if you overrule this you
might they might overrule the gay
marriage decision or the lawrence v
texas decision which legalizes
homosexual sodomy or finds
constitutional right to it or they might
overrule contraception or they might
have a rule whatever it's just all this
fear-mongering that isn't true by the
way if you read the majority decision
and is is beside the point as well it
shows you how desperate they are if if
they could
argue
the the point on abortion they would but
they can't so they have to misdirect to
things like miscarriages next question
hey michael
came for ben stayed for you
i'm a conservative protestant preacher
and often when i'm putting together my
sermons i like to pull inspiration from
some of my roman catholic brothers from
the past john chrysostom for example
i was wondering if there are any
protestant preachers that you like to
you quote
c.s lewis quite a bit uh who
is
you know near catholic but are there any
others that you've read or looked into
thanks for everything bye
great question
uh certainly john henry newman
that's a little bit of a cheating answer
because john henry newman was a
very
anti-catholic
anglican
uh prelate and theologian and then he
became he converted to catholicism in
the oxford movement and
became not only a catholic cardinal but
a catholic saint um so that one's a
little bit cheating yes there are there
are uh protestants who i
think of a lot and read a fair bit uh
one of the protestants who helped bring
me back to christianity from atheism was
alvin plantinga the analyst he's an
analytic philosopher so he's not exactly
a preacher
but he is a
i guess you'd call him a protestant
theologian he did his own version of the
modal ontological argument for god so he
would be one of them i don't agree with
him on everything and fundamentally on
theology i don't agree with him but i
i've read him and quoted him a fair bit
and then another one i love is richard
niebur
the protestant ethicist who had a line
that i quote frequently which is that
modern religion
is a god without wrath leading a people
without sin into a kingdom without
judgment through the ministrations of a
christ without a cross
love that line great line from from
niebuhr okay next question
hey michael long time listener first
time caller
i am totally in love with my boyfriend
and we have been talking about getting
married and having oodles of babies
the problem is
that i'm pro-life and he's pro-choice i
believe that life begins at conception
the scientific and biological
perspective
and he believes that before sentience at
12 to 14 weeks it's not a life it's a
potential life to me that makes no sense
i say it's a life with potential
the biggest issue though is that two of
his girlfriends in the past have had
abortions
had abortions before the 14-week point
he thinks that he did a good thing by
doing it so quickly and won't accept
that he helped to end the lives of two
innocent babies
that worries me
because
what if you know he counsels our future
children to do the same
thing if the situation arose
what should i do how can i counter his
argument that
is biologically philosophically lacking
also
he thinks that i believe him to be a
murderer
but i don't
and even if i did believe that he was a
murderer
based on the definition of murder
his judgment will be in the hereafter
and
i cannot
would not pass judgment on him that's
for god to decide
i welcome your counsel
love the show well thank you
he is a murderer
he is i think
even you need to accept that point by
your own logic he is a murderer
murderers can be forgiven
they can uh saint paul though not
exactly a murderer probably saint paul
was he participated in the stoning of
saint stephen he was present for it
didn't didn't object
he's
one of the greatest apostles in history
the culpability for any sin including
murder is mitigated somewhat if you are
not fully aware of what you are doing
and that may have been the case with
your boyfriend with the abortion if he
genuinely didn't know that the baby is a
baby maybe he sincerely believed that
the baby wasn't really a baby
maybe he wasn't maybe he was unsure or
maybe he was just really freaked out
but
that that would mitigate guilt in some
way too i mean the argument that he's
making
that the baby isn't a baby is as you say
biologically
and uh and philosophically absurd uh he
probably knows that
and he probably feels guilty in the fact
that he's saying you think i'm a
murderer i think
i think he's probably talking about
himself
who who are you really talking about
here buddy who are you really trying to
convince
he probably knows the idea that it's a
potential life doesn't mean anything
from the moment of conception the baby
has all of the characteristics of life
and the baby is obviously a human so
it's a human life
and even even if we say potential life
what does that even mean
it's not a potential life in the way the
sperm or an egg are potential lives it's
a complete
life it's a this unique human being so i
i bet he probably knows that deep down
and i bet he probably feels just an
extreme amount of guilt the way to get
out of that guilt though is not to deny
deny deny deny that's what our culture
tells us to do it says don't be ashamed
of anything you've ever done
it's not even wrong don't even think
it's wrong don't there's no wrong and
right it's just it's cool man you know
that gnawing guilt that your conscience
is poking you with all the time yeah
just ignore that just dead in that with
drugs and
and distractions and
sex and overwork and whatever just don't
acknowledge it that's not that's not
going to be
a path to success or redemption you need
to first acknowledge it the only way out
is through and i think your boyfriend
should probably just look himself in the
mirror and say you know what
my my fiancee or my girlfriend thinks
i'm a murderer
i guess i am i guess i am and i did a
horrible horrible thing twice i did a
really horrible thing twice and maybe i
didn't totally know
and maybe
maybe i did know and maybe but i did it
and people do really horrible things and
there and i can be forgiven and i can
repent even for that
but you've
first you've got to acknowledge it the
first the first step is acknowledging
that reality and then i you know you
know what i would recommend i'd
recommend you uh you know go to he he go
to confession he he asked god's
forgiveness and he really work on all of
that that's going to be the only way out
because your concern is is totally
legitimate you're going to get married
he's going to be the head of your
household and uh even even if he were
not the head of household this would
this would
you're talking about the way you're
going to raise children and you're
talking about some of the most
fundamental questions of life and death
and what is a human being what is the
nature of man so you really should be on
the same page here and he probably can
be and he's probably racked with guilt
and he should work through that if he
gets on the path to working through that
then i say go on have a happy marriage
if he refuses to work through that i
think you're going to see
the
downsides you're going to see negative
effects of that spread out in so many
other areas of your marriage so deal
with it don't ignore it deal deal with
that man in the mirror i'm michael
knowles this is michael miller have a
happy fourth of july see you next time
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the ben shapiro show jordan
peterson joins daily wire plus same day
twitter bans him for observing that
women actually exist and the white house
and democrats continue to overstep on
abortion that's today on the bench
bureau shall give it a listen